(dramatic music)
(lasso whipping)
(cow mooing)
- [Announcer] We got one
round left, Ms. Joanna Stern.
(upbeat music)
(grunts)
- Airpods Pro in.
That's me, regretting this idea I had
to test how well these
things stay in your ears.
I even had to double down on my testing
with one of New York City's
most iconic dance families.
(slow opera music)
Why did I do this?
Well, because unlike the
$150 regular Airpods,
the $250 Airpods Pro have
active noise cancellation.
They come with three different
size silicon rubber tips
to better fit in your ear.
Plus, Airpods have been known to fall out.
(dramatic opera music)
There's even a size test
that analyzes the fit
when they're in your ears and
tells you if you're all good.
Heck, Apple's so confident in the fit,
they made them sweat
resistant for working out.
I tested four wireless
earbuds on the bull:
the standard Airpods, the Airpods Pro,
the Samsung Galaxy buds,
and the Amazon Echo buds.
With each pair in, I
asked the bull operator
to drive at three speeds.
Slow, medium, and high.
Yeah.
The regular Airpods
stayed in on all the tests
except for one.
(buzzing)
One out.
Yeah.
(grunting)
Galaxy buds in.
(dinging)
Amazon Echo buds.
The Amazon Echo buds faired the worst,
falling out both times I fell.
(buzzing)
Amazon ear buds, oh
no, they both fell out.
Amazon does include these
wing tips in the box,
which should help.
Though, even then, they're
still the least comfortable
of the bunch.
I'm not sure this was my best idea.
(light classical music)
The Airpod Pros would not fall out
no matter how many times I was bumped off.
They just stayed securely in my ears.
Didn't even really
(dinging)
loosen up.
(grunting)
(dinging)
More good news about the Pros.
If you're ever riding a mechanical bull
while trying to enjoy
some music, as one does,
the Pros active noise
canceling blocked out
the machinery better than
those other competitors.
Of course, that could also
mean it would block out
the sound of an oncoming train or car.
That's why there's a transparency.
You switch it on via the
phone or by pressing on
this little button to hear
more noises around you.
Okay, so the Airpods Pros
survived the mechanical bull.
But I had to find one
more test just to be sure.
(bright woodwind music)
This is Tic, Tac, oh and Tay.
Not only do Tic and Tac do crazy tricks,
but they're twins with similar ears.
So I gave them two pairs of Airpods Pro
and well, got outta the way.
Airpods are staying in.
Again, the Airpods Pros
stayed in insanely well.
Are they in?
- Yeah!
- [Joanna] They're still in?
- Yeah.
(dinging)
- Still stayed in.
- [Joanna] We even had Tay,
another member of the family,
test them out.
(light music)
- Almost out.
- And with that, we finally got the
Airpods Pro to fall out
(buzzing)
with a series of clips.
You're still good, so one fell out!
(phone ringing)
Are you (beep) kidding me?
Yes, after all of that, it turns out
aggressive chewing is what
can loosen up the in ear seal.
Still, these things
stay in extremely well.
Did it come out?